cent so President Trump did not inherit
a messy and hurted a momentum of jobs
creation when President Obama came into
office the stock market was at 6,000
when he left it was at 18,000 again
momentum that the administration was
able to build on not a mess the during
the eight years of the Obama President
Obama's presidency he reduced the
deficit by a trillion dollars instead
this administration is increasing the
trillion dollars and of course with
their tax cut their tax scam for the 83
percent senator the benefits going to
the top one percent they increased the
national debt by two trillion dollars
and therefore they tried to it's
supposed to pay for itself but instead
they went to Medicare and Medicaid to
try to pay for that but we're not doing
that
and then during join the eight years of
President and when President Bush was
president the job growth was slow under
President Obama we gained more than 14
million private-sector jobs and during
his presidency more than and that is far
more in a program in terms of years than
what this president has created a
momentum a path of 14 million dollars is
not a mess mr. president and then during
the presidency we rescued the auto
industry and all that that brought back
to the economy and during the
administration more than 20 million
people were for that quality affordable
health care but more in addition to that
150 million families with pre-existing
conditions I got a new benefit that
enabled them to have access to health
care as well as other benefits of no
lifetime than no annual limit child is
of until 26 years old can stay on your
benefit being a woman no longer a
pre-existing condition so when he talks
about old I'm going to make health care
the fact is
he did not he did not inherit the mess
he heard a momentum of growth in our
economy and many more statistics are in
it what I hope you will read because it
was appalling to hear him try to take
credit for something that he and call
what the President Obama did a mess that
he inherited when in fact it was a great
advantage to the country that President
Obama's policies took us to that very
positive place of growth and of job
creation and deficit reduction and I
talked to my members and they have ideas
I always say what does your idea do for
growth for creation of good-paying jobs
and reducing the deficit let's see how
it meets those standards what the
president has done it is not that and so
for him to make it as if he did all this
stuff long ago she still hasn't even
matched President Obama's growth in the
stock market if you call that a real
measure of success and in some respects
it's a good indicator but it's not an
indicator of what is happening at the
kitchen tables of America's working
families where they're concerned about
the fact that many of them have not
received a raise in a very long time
that where the percent of them could not
find $500 for an emergency president
goes on and saying oh it's a many more
because of all my growth many more
people are not orange food said no you
kicked him off I know people are not
taking advantage of this no you kicked
them off and that just isn't a fair
thing to do in our economy so it was a
in my view of Manifesto of mistruths
falsehoods blatantly really dangerous to
the well-being of the American people if
they believed what he said so again we
do not want chamber of the House of
Representatives to be used as a backdrop
for one of those reality shows with
unreality in his presentation and by the
way a serious breach
to start shouting four more years on the
floor of the house totally inappropriate
we're very excited about how we're going
forward to honor our promises to
American people for the people we were
going to lower the cost of health care
by lowering cost of prescription drugs
and we're on our path with HR 3 saw
people heavily enough the three HR three
maybe just three benefits from that
people should know that it will lower
the cost of prescription drugs for them
it will also increase benefits in
Medicare at dental hearing and visual a
vision and the expansion of Medicare
which is the biggest expansion since its
inception that that benefit will apply
to not only Medicare the the reduction
in cost will not only apply to Medicare
but to all other insurance plans for
help for prescription drugs are very
excited about HR 3 lower health care
costs by lowering the cost of
prescription drugs and protecting the
pre-existing medical condition benefit
secondly bigger paychecks building the
infrastructure of America and a green
resilient way we thought we were a good
place on both of those scores with the
president because we had negotiated with
the White House on HR 3 until the
president decided to go with Pharma and
instead of with the American people
thought we were a good path in
negotiating with the administration on
what the infrastructure bill would
continue as now you talked about rural
broadband he didn't even know what that
was when we first talking about it so
just roads and stopping on roads bridges
a water broadband and the rest and so
they were paychecks by doing it we
talked about some unique plan he sent
over a two hundred billion dollar plan
which he then said is a bad plan it is
it's too small too too much burden on
the localities so we had really
important and then of course our third
agenda lower health care costs bigger
paychecks cleaner government we think we
have a shot with him in the first two
but not on the third
government no that's not something that
they they he or the Republicans have as
a value so yesterday the Senate acted
first time in history the senator has
voted against his own president in a
decision regarding impeachment god bless
him for his courage
this morning the president said when
present people use faith that an excuse
to do I don't just have bad things but
whatever he said it was just so
completely inappropriate especially at a
prayer breakfast so again we will be
expanding our what we talked about
before about our infrastructure bill
surface transportation water systems
broadband rural broadband urban desert
broadband a very important to health
education commerce in the rest for our
country and then we'll go further with
our initiatives on infrastructure for
education for school construction and
some housing initiatives and initiatives
that relate to our the needs of our
veterans will be unfolding some of that
in the week ahead so we continue
continue continued through our world 275
or more bipartisan bills on Mitch
McConnell's desk
the grim reaper has not taken any of
them up if he had one I wish he would do
I have my bullet here what she would do
background check legislation which would
save lives so it is an interesting time
as we go forward we'll also be taking up
in the next week the ER a the
legislation related to the ER a and
there's a great deal of excitement
across the country you see what happened
in Virginia and we're hoping to move the
date to include that that new state in
that number to promote women especially
in this year when we observed the 100th
anniversary of women having the right to
vote I know what you're gonna say Chad
what happened to the 49ers yeah but but
just when you're thinking of it think
about your own team okay
[Laughter]
there's always that there's always that
any question yes man yes well we've had
a string relationship for a while and we
were able to keep government open and
push back on his um threats to shut down
government if we didn't do this and we
didn't do that and that's right and I
was very proud of the work in a
bipartisan way of our appropriators left
to their own devices you've heard me say
they can really work things out and we
did and we push back on any threats have
shut down so we've worked together on
that we work together on the us/mexico
can agreement a he bragged about
delivering it I don't know if he even
knows what's in it because it's so far
different of whatever he sent us to
begin with but it does have what I've
said to you many times it did does have
a framework of enforcement for
protection of our workers protection of
our environment and getting rid of his
gift to farm imagine he had a gift to
Pharma in that and that trade agreement
will we kick kicked that out just
another example of his behold earnest to
the pharmaceutical industry so we we've
got two major things accomplished these
are things the president said he wanted
to do reduce the cost of prescription
drug and build the infrastructure during
the campaign especially infrastructure I
hardly ever had a conversation with him
when he wasn't talking about
infrastructure infrastructure
infrastructure I think he really wants
that I think he knows our country needs
that and I hope that we we were almost
there and the till it's time to pay for
it and then he was out the door well
that would be up to him it certainly
hasn't changed in terms of us as people
said to me why would you give him a
victory
on the trade agreement I said it's not
victory for him not to do that for the
benefit it provides for our farmers our
manufacturers our workers and our
country our hemisphere
my back it would be wrong I mean you
just wasn't that important that we would
walk away from what they were conceding
to us but they were conceding to us in
that legislation if we didn't get what
we want we couldn't go that path but we
did now doing it we get everything now
was a negotiation but it's a path to a
much better trade agreement at least we
did it
well I don't think that has anything to
do just say that that that language is
first of all the whole state of the
union was beneath the dignity of the
White House an insult to the Congress of
the United States and American people so
their language is nothing that surprises
anyone but they have to know during the
White House speaks those words weigh a
ton and they are giving encouragement to
people to do things just says remember
Charlottesville people are coming down
that hill with tiki torches saying the
Jews will not replace us the Jews will
not replace us and what was the
president's statements they're good
people on both sides really the Jews
will not replaces and good people on
both sides so they there's a mysterious
view that they have about what their
words wait their words carry and there
are people out there who for whatever
purpose I know I'm constantly I'm not I
don't want even go into the target that
I am because of them but I can't worry
about that but that was there even
before them just working with President
Obama stirred up some of those same
people but the I know I would like to
think that it had nothing to do with
what the White House was saying but I do
think they should rein in their comments
but that's what they're saying is
they're going to be payback to us for
upholding the Constitution of the United
States for honoring the vision of our
founders for a democracy a Republican we
can keep it for something that our men
and women in uniform fight to protect
our freedom our Constitution and the
aspirations of our children that depend
on living in the democracy that is on
question in terms of that well we have
freedom of the press to be guardians of
that democracy so you know I'm not very
fond of commenting on anything they say
but if it's threat
it's wrong I want first salute our
managers I think they did a magnificent
job and presenting the case for our
founders for our Constitution for a
country we could not have been better
served each and every one of them did a
magnificent job and I'm ships liberally
Dersch ap-- was a blessing to our
country I'm proud of the work that the
Senate did in terms of their response to
all of this and they're the unanimous
vote of the House Democrats in support
of our Constitution we are now that the
Senate has spoken in terms of any
punishment to the president he's
impeached forever no matter what he says
or whatever headlines he wants to carry
around
you're impeached forever you're never
getting rid of that scar and history
will always record that you were
impeached for undermining the security
of our country
jeopardizing the integrity of our
elections and violating the Constitution
of the United States our purpose in all
of this in addition to holding him
accountable so he stops doing what he's
doing and no future president thinks
that she or he could have Liberty to
take us away from the republic if you
can keep it to a second amendment
enables me to do whatever I want no
that's not what our Constitution is
about so we will continue to do our
oversight to protect and defend the
Constitution which is three co-equal
branches of government each a check and
balance on the other and some we have
some cases in court now McCann taxes and
that and and that will take time we
didn't need to have that come to a
fruition with that because we had a
strong enough case to impeach and remove
but those cases still exist if there are
others that we see and it's an
opportunity we'll make a judgement at
that time but we have no plans right
I don't know if the president
understands about prayer or people who
do pray but we do pray for the United
States of America pray for him I present
President Bush still President Obama
because it's a heavy responsibility and
pray hard for him because he's so off
the track of our Constitution our values
our country the air our children breathe
the water they drink and the rest he
really needs our prayers so he could say
whatever he wants he can say whatever he
wants but I do pray for him and I do so
sincerely and without anguish you know I
gently duff's why I pray for everybody
else I thought what he said about what
he said about Senator Romney was
particularly without class way to say
there's some people use faith as an
excuse to do the wrong things that you
remember what he said about Romney
you're not that there what it but it's
so inappropriate at a prayer breakfast
you won't go the prayer breath is prone
to school vouchers woman's right to
choose all those things that that's a
ripe audience for god bless you that's
it's a prayer breakfast and that's
something about faith you know it may
not be something I agree with but it's a
purpose but to go into the stock market
and raising up his acquittal thing and
mischaracterizing other people's
motivation
he's talking about things that he knows
little about faith and prayer yes men
yes no it did not no did not I tore up a
manifesto of mistruths it very hard for
us to get you to talk about the issues
that we are working on HR 3
infrastructure and the rest he
misrepresented all of that was necessary
to get the attention of the American
people to say this is not true and this
is how it affects you and I don't need
any lessons from anybody especially at
present United States about dignity
dignity is it okay to start saying four
more years and the House of
Representatives it's just unheard of
unheard of for the president to insult
people there who don't share his view as
well as to misrepresent present
falsehoods some would use the word lie I
don't like to use the word lie about
what he is saying so no I think it was
completely entirely appropriate and
considering some of the other exuberance
--is within me the courteous thing to do
well next year we will have a new
president of the United States that is
an absolute imperative for our country
for our constitution for the land that
we love from sea to shining sea which he
degrades almost every day but several
times a week for who we are as a people
a nation of immigrants unless you're
blessed to be born a Native American a
nation of who he denigrates and for our
values what she just is disloyal to the
Constitution degrades the environment
denigrates who we are as a people and
and undervalues who we are as a great
country that is a good that is a good
country where people care about each
other and where there's a sense of
community it's appalling the things that
he says and then you say to me I'm
tearing up his falsehoods isn't that the
wrong mess no it isn't
it's just I have tried to be gracious
with him
I'm always dignified I thought that was
a very dignified act compared to my
super honest as I said but we will not
allow any president to use that capital
that chamber of the House of
Representatives of the people's health
was a backdrop for him now all
presidents have guests constant guests
that was not a State of the Union that
was a state his state of mind we weren't
a State of the Union where are we where
we're going and the rest not let me just
show you how many guests I can draw and
let me say how I can give a Medal of
Honor do it in your own office we don't
come in your office and do congressional
business why are you doing that here
quite frankly when he started talking
about someone with stage-4 can't all of
that I thought he was I don't know what
stage John Lewis's cancer is that but
when you start talking about someone
with cancer we thought it was going to
talk about John Lewis hero in our
country so in any event I feel very
liberated I feel very liberated I feel
that I've extended every possible
courtesy I've shown every level of
respect I say to my numbers all the time
there's no such thing as an eternal
animosity there are ternal friendships
but you never know on what cause you may
come together with somebody who may
perceive as your foe right now everybody
is a possible ally and whatever comes
next
he pluribus unum for many one didn't
know how many would be or how different
we be but they wanted us always to
remember that we were one and they our
founders had their differences as do we
so again I extended the hand of
friendship to him to welcome him as the
president of United States to the
people's house was also an act of
kindness because I to me like he was a
little sedated be looked that way last
year too but he didn't want to shake
hands
that was that that meant nothing to me
it had nothing to do with my tearing up
that that came much later and you know a
speed reader I just went right through
that thing so I knew what was coming
when I saw the compilation of falsehoods
and but then when I heard like the first
quarter or third I and I started to
think there has to be something that
clearly indicates the American people
that this is not the truth and he has
shredded the truth in his speech he's
shredding the Constitution and his
conduct I shredded his state of his mind
address thank you all very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a very historic and very
significant roaring we've had these five
elections before this one in Palau